Today we're going to talk about the
number one most dangerous carb in the
world and it's not sugar. Okay, even by
a long shot. This carbohydrate creates
such a massive blood sugar spike, way
more than sugar, but it's not even
classified as a sugar. It's a carb, but
it's not a sugar. It has the potential
to create diabetes type two and a fatty
liver and insulin resistance which is
the precursor to type 2 diabetes. In
other words, it will mess with your
blood sugar big time. It's going to
create visceral fat. That's the fat
around your organs. It will disrupt your
good microbes and feed the pathogens,
the bad guys in your gut. It is a
superinflammatory
carbohydrate. It'll create inflammation,
not just in your joints, but especially
in your gut. If you're ever concerned
about the true bad cholesterol, the LDL,
small particles that can invade the
inside of the arteries, this is one carb
that will do it in a heartbeat. It's
marketed as zero sugars. It only costs
20 cents per pound. So, this is a bucket
of it right here. This is 25 pounds.
Pretty heavy. This is five bucks. And
that's because it's subsidized. That
means the taxpayers actually end up
fronting the money for it so they can
get it at a fraction of the real cost.
All right. What's the purpose of this
carbohydrate? It has no health benefits.
It's a filler. Okay. It adds bulk to a
product. An average person consumes
between 65 and 250 pounds of this stuff
every single year. That comes out to 21
billion pounds of this carbohydrate
produced every year. It's in a lot of
the gluten-free foods. It's in baby
formulas. It's in baked goods. A lot of
athletes consume it. Can you now guess
what this carb is? It is
a starch, but not just any old starch.
Not the potatoes that your grandmother
served you. We're talking about
industrial starch, modified food starch,
corn starch, malttodextrin.
All right. What is a starch? This is a
starch right here. We have sugar over
here. A starch is a string of sugar
molecules on a chain. But when you
modify it in the lab, you strip away all
the armor. You now refine it and break
it down to such a level that these bonds
between the sugar become very very weak
and fragile. So when you consume it, it
breaks down into sugar so fast, even
more than glucose. So when I talk about
industrial starch, I'm not talking about
these potatoes or even the starch and
vegetables. I'm talking about this
powder right here. this powder that has
been so highly refined. And what I mean
by refined, it's mechanically ground
down into small particles. They add
bleach. But of course, if you consume
this in a spoon, it would not be very
pleasurable. It's not even that sweet
unless you chewed it for a while.
Because if you chewed it, in fact, if
you even took a piece of bread in your
mouth, it wouldn't be sweet unless you
chewed it a little bit and you broke
down the bonds to release the sugar and
then it would be sweet. I'm going to run
through very quickly just the chemicals
that they use in this modification. You
really need to know this. One chemical
they use is called sodium triet
phosphate. This has been linked to
kidney stress and vascular
calcification. It may worsen bone
demineralization and accelerate aging
process in arteries. Here's another one.
Vinyl acetate. Vinyl acetate is
considered a possible human carcinogen.
Here's another one. Sodium
hypocchlorite. This is bleach. Bleach is
interesting because they regulate bleach
in the water supplies as a carcinogen,
but they don't regulate it in the food
starch. Overexposure is linked to kidney
stress and damage to your enamel and
mucosal tissues. And then they add this
other chemical. This is widely used in
infant formulas and beverages. It may
disrupt mitochondrial function if
consumed in excess. So here's the point.
All of those chemicals I just mentioned
are self-regulated
under something called gross, which is
generally recognized as safe. And so the
question is, how can it actually be safe
if it's not even tested for long-term
studies? And so you don't have to really
wonder why we have chronic disease. If
we look at this, okay, we have 16 gram
of total carbohydrate, we have 1 g of
fiber, and we have 0 g of sugar. what is
left. We have 15 grams of a carbohydrate
that is not listed on this nutritional
facts. And that is why starch is
invisible. You don't see it unless you
read the ingredients and understand that
modified food starch, modified corn
starch, wheat starch are all industrial
starches. It's basically extra damaged
protein that clogs everything up. It's
directly responsible for the
complications of diabetes and also the
Alzheimer's plaquing in the brain and
also the fibrosis or scar tissue in your
liver. But there's one more thing I need
to mention without giving you a lot of
big words. This is the word right here
which is a byproduct of glucose from the
starch. It's called an eldahhide. I
don't know if you ever heard about this
chemical, but this is what they use to
inbalm people, to preserve them. The
other one is another chemical that I'm
not going to give you the long name on.
All you need to realize is that it's the
toxin that occurs after you drink
alcohol the day after when you have the
hangover. But don't worry, it gets
worse. If you take a look at junk food,
right, what is it composed of? Sugar,
starch, and seed oils, right? But when
you combine the starch with the seed oil
under heat, you create a compounded
toxic soup that is deadly on your
tissues. Very few people just consume
starch by itself. They have it in
different forms like chips, right?
Potato chips, which is mostly seed oil
and refined industrial starch. And if
you go in the snack aisle in the grocery
store, you'll see all sorts of versions
of these chips or crunchy things with
basically seed oil and more starch. I
mean, chips have like 65% starch, 30%
oil. Then we get crackers. Here's the
Cheeits, right? 70% starch, 25% seed
oils. Then we have cereals. 80% starch.
Sometimes they put seed oils, but mostly
they add sugar to that, but there's
usually always some seed oil involved.
What have we got in bread? 75% starch.
Maybe some sugar, but definitely seed
oils, 15%. Pasta has starch. We have 15%
seed oils. French fries, 80% starch, 15%
seed oils. So, what's really bizarre to
me is that so many of us have been
focused on sugar for so many years, but
the starch is actually consumed in way
higher quantities and actually it's more
deadly. Now, remember, I'm not just
picking on starches. I'm not picking on
this potato you'd get from the garden or
vegetable starches. I'm picking on the
industrial starches like these mashed
potatoes that have been highly
processed. There's a big difference
between you cooking this and you just
adding water to this right here. But of
course, some people say, "I don't eat
corn starch." But then if you look in
their pantry, they usually have some
Poptart or some other food that has
modified corn starch. But because they
don't read the label, they don't know.
And then they'll tell me, "Well, it's
organic, but look at how much starch and
seed oils that are in here. It's the
same as non-organic." What's pretty wild
is I was in the grocery store the other
day and I bought these hot dogs. The
third ingredient is modified food starch
in hot dogs. Why? Because it's a filler
to add bulk. So if we look at the
definition of food, that which is eaten
to sustain life, promote the growth and
repair of tissues. Does the ingredients
in ultrarocessed food calories aka junk
food, industrial starch, fit this
definition? No, it does not fit the
biological definition of the word food
and it shouldn't be called food, but it
is because of various loopholes that is
built into the legal definition of food,
which is a completely different
conversation. I'll do another video just
on that. So, they can actually keep
selling it and calling it food. The
basic three ingredients for most junk
food, ultrarocessed foods, sugar,
usually synthetic sugar, makes up 5 to
20% of that. Seed oils makes up 20 to
35% of that. And starches make up the
majority, 55 to 75% of ultrarocessed
food calories are starches. And I
created a really cool app for you to use
to identify these three things. All you
have to do is download the free app and
then scan the barcode on any box of food
and it'll quickly represent these three
things. So you can visually see how much
of these are in the foods in your
pantry, in your refrigerator, or at the
grocery store. Unfortunately, 65% of the
calories young children eat are
ultrarocessed foods and 55 pounds of
that is just industrial starch. When you
get to teenagers, it's 70% of their
calories are ultrarocessed foods. And
that's over 106 pounds of actual
industrial starch. Now, these numbers
are extremely conservative. It's
probably a lot more, but it's just one
reference that I found. Adults have 55%
of their calories ultrarocessed food and
67 pounds of industrial starch. I mean,
it's mind-blowing that the great
majority of our calories are
ultrarocessed food calories. Now, I
really gave starches a black eye, okay?
But the next most important thing you
need to understand is the data about
seed oils. And for that video, you
should watch, I put it up right here.
Check it out right now.